SPEAKER 1: So a
vertical guideline
is, basically you can think of
it as a new edge of the screen.
So it's like I have one
on the left of the screen.
I have one on the right screen.
And now I've put an
edge of the screen
in the middle of the
screen that I can use
as an anchor for constraints.
I'm going to go ahead
and move that to where
I'd like it in my design.
And now, I could just
take those text views
and create constraints from
those to this guideline.
And to kind of visualize what
this is doing underneath,
if I move the
guideline, it's actually
going to move the
entire layout now.
So if we go into Helpers and
we use Add Vertical Barrier,
this allows you to add
a barrier to the screen.
And what a barrier is, is it's
kind of like a view group.
And it's actually
called a grouping code.
So we can open up
the componentry,
select our email and
password, and drag that down
to be inside of our barrier.
Now, it's not
actually a view group.
It's just a view that's
added to the screen.
It's positioned on one side or
the other of all of the views
that are inside of it.
Right?
By default, it's on the left,
but if I open up the Attributes
pane and scroll
down to the bottom,
I'm going to find a
barrier direction, which
I can set to the end.
And now that I've done that, I'm
going to set up my constraints
and then translate my
English over to German.
And everything's going
to relay out and do
exactly what I expected.
SPEAKER 2: We've added the
ability to add constraints
directly with the context menu.
So in this case, if
you have components
that are really
close to each other,
this makes it a lot more precise
and more direct to actually set
those constraints.
So in this case--
and this is
available in 3.3 beta
as well, so you can
try it out today.
And so in this case, we
select one component,
which we have this
lovely cat picture.
You can just simply
constrain it to the parent.
So what does it look like if
you have multiple components?
So in this case, we have
these two text views that
are really close to each other.
And so, I'm not
sure if people have
tried to create constraints
between two text views
that almost overlap--
it becomes a little
painful when you're
going from the bottom of
one to the top of the other.
And so with this
new Context menu,
you can actually just
keep the two selected.
And then when you open
up the Context menu,
there's now this Constrain menu.
And so you can actually just
see that the two elements
that you want to use are there.
And then you can easily
cascade to the right constraint
that you want.
The design surfaces has always
had a bunch of view options
to take advantage of when you're
working with your layouts.
So the two I'll talk about
specifically which we added
is Show All Constraints
and Live Rendering.
What we've done
in Android Studio
3.3 is we've added this option
to show all constraints.
But it's actually
turned off by default.
And so here's a quick video to
show you what that looks like.
And so what we'll do
instead is we only
show the constraints on the
actively selected component.
So this makes it easier to
just work with the component
that you're actually
working with,
and not be distracted by all
the arrows and margins that
usually come with the layout.
The other view option we
have is Live Rendering.
So we've actually done
live rendering by default
in constraint layout
for quite some time.
And so it's on by
default. But depending
on the specs of your
machine [INAUDIBLE],,
it can actually
be a little slow.
You've actually been able to
zoom and pan in the layout
editor for a while now.
And it comes really
in handy when
you're dealing with constraint
layouts, especially when,
again, when things
are really small
or when they're really close
to each other or overlapping.
But what we've done in
3.3 is we've actually
changed the keyboard
shortcuts to match
more of what we expect from
the design tools like Photoshop
and Sketch.
And so to zoom in, you can
use Command or Control,
depending on what OS you're
on, and then the equals sign.
And then with the mouse wheel,
you can hold Command or Control
and scroll up.
And then if you have a trackpad,
you can just pinch in to zoom.
Then the opposite
is for zoom out.
So it's Command and Control
minus, then Command and Control
with the mouse wheel to
scroll down, and then pinch
in the opposite direction.
And then zoom to fit.
So if you're zoomed in and you
want to get back to that layout
where you can see
the whole thing,
you can just use Command
and Control plus 0.
And so then, if you're zoomed
in and you don't actually
want to zoom out, but
you want to pan around,
you can actually do so by
holding Space and then using
the mouse to click and drag.
[MUSIC PLAYING]